you did a great job at the Oscars Elsa
your beautiful dress was one of the most
memorable looks of the whole ceremony
however during your performance we felt
like we were seeing double you didn't
have some friends up on stage with you
did you if you watch the 2020 Oscars
you'll probably remember the
spellbinding performance of into the
unknown from frozen - aside from
featuring idina menzel this performance
was iconic for many reasons
it featured not one but ten women who
voiced Elsa in frozen - that's a lot of
star power with frozen - available in 45
languages it's no wonder the film has
had international success let's take a
trip around the world to meet these
show-stopping ladies it's no wonder
someone with a successful background in
pop music would be ideal for the role of
voicing our beloved Elsa the song into
the unknown is a fantastic blend of pop
and contemporary musical theatre this
musical style requires a performer to
sing with the vocal nuance of a pop star
and the range of someone classically
trained for musical theater
luckily Maria Lucia Heiberg Rosenberg
was up for the challenge having a few
chart-topping pop singles under her belt
this Elsa from Denmark was a perfect fit
and we're glad she got to sing at the
Oscars she's no stranger to Disney
either throughout your career Maria has
performed in Danish language versions of
several Disney musicals some of her
notable performances include Belle from
Beauty and the Beast and Jasmine in
Aladdin she was also in a rendition of
West Side Story and played Elphaba in
wicked do you know any of these musicals
let us know in the comments
filmin ver kayak has a long history with
Disney and musical theater she played
alfafa in multiple productions of wicked
including a Broadway performance in 2013
she's the only actress to have played
the role in more than one language she
was in the Broadway London Dutch and
German versions of wicked when you add
all of her performances of Elphaba
together she played the role over 2,000
times she's also voiced Elsa in frozen -
in the dutch and german version we want
to know how many languages for kyuk
speaks and to all you Abba fans out
there she also played Donna in Mamma Mia
for a brief time in between the wicked
productions her personal life is a
little more relaxed as she says some of
her favorite pastimes include
bird-watching and hiking with her
husband Bart Vaughn who who's also a
notable Dutch musician she says she
likes these pastimes because they
provide a counterbalance to her hectic
professional life takaku matzah was born
learning mushy boo a type of traditional
Japanese dance many times people who
learned this kind of dance grow up to do
it professionally or have happy careers
in show business
Takako Matsu was no exception as she
came from a star-studded family her
uncle and father were also famous
Japanese actors as well Matsu starred in
her first theater role when she was just
16 years old and has since enjoyed a
successful career in both film
television and theatrical productions
throughout her life some of her notable
stage performances include playing Kim
in the hit musical Miss Saigon in 2004
aside from acting on the screen and
stage she has also published a book of
essays and recorded a few studio albums
her performance of Elsa was just one of
many entries in her impressive resume we
think she did a great job at the Oscars
born in Nuevo lardo Mexico in 1982 Miss
Carmen is a frozen sensation
she's voiced Elsa in frozen Disney
infinity
once upon a time frozen fever Lego
frozen Northern Lights
Olaf's frozen adventure and of course
frozen - for Latin America she's the
number one Elsa she's very active on
Instagram and always keeps followers up
to date on all of her most recent
professional endeavors and sometimes she
shares pictures of her adorable children
she also recently made a touching
tribute to Kobe Bryant on her Instagram
as well showing that this proud mother
cares deeply for many people around the
world like many other international
Elsa's lisa has had quite an impressive
career on Broadway she is an actress and
singer active in both Norway and Britain
some of her most notable theatrical
performances include Sophie in the
original West End cast of Mamma Mia in
1993 as well as a performance of Guys
and Dolls you'd think being Elsa was a
full-time job but this Disney Princess
also has a business outside of the
silver screen lisa has recently entered
the entrepreneurial world going into
business with Arbonne a health company
she's been shown promoting several
arbonne products on her Instagram on her
Arbonne dot-com profile she says she
wanted something that would provide
financial security to her family show
business can be rewarding but it's never
reliable work and as a mother of two she
wanted to enter an industry that would
guarantee steady work and one where she
could set her own hours instead of being
at the whim of agents and directors
hopefully she's found a good balance
heads up Steven universe fans cat Rosine
Alaska the voice of Elsa in Poland also
voiced pearl in the Polish version of
Steven universe she also performed in
Greece West Side Story lame is Chicago
and Miss Saigon throughout her
theatrical career her name may be a
little hard to pronounce for some of her
fans so she also goes by cassia Alaska
born in Poland in 1979 this 40-year old
actress has had a very impressive career
in show business starting her
professional career in 1995 here's a
blast from the past for all you nineties
kids out there cassia voiced Musa in the
Polish version of the Winx Club the Winx
Club was an animated children's TV show
that featured a group of young Enchantix
fairies as they used their powers to
fight crime while also navigating the
difficult terrain of high school what do
you think of kasia's performance at the
2020 oscars give this video a like if
you loved the beautiful sequined dress
she was wearing we've got a hand it to
Anna boot ralina she really did a
phenomenal job at the Oscars performance
her singing was perfect and her stage
presence was powerful we could have
watched her sing all day for someone
with such powerful pipes it only makes
sense Anna was classically trained as a
jazz singer in her early childhood
specifically she went to the neason
state Music College and specialized in
pop jazz since graduating she has
released five studio albums many of
which include jazz ballads she has also
done many live tours with concertos and
group orchestras it's no surprise
someone with a singing background such
as Anna's would have some experience in
musical theatre as well some of her
performances in musical theatre include
playing Maria in West Side Story French
she and Greece and Wendy in the Peter
Pan musical for television she voiced
Princess cadance
in the Russian dubbing of My Little Pony
Friendship is Magic
[Music]
born in Barcelona in 1979 he Silla as
she's commonly referred to is a Spanish
pop icon and dubbing actress before she
got into show business she was a
journalism student at the Autonomous
University of Barcelona she also
competed in Eurovision in 2008 when she
represented Andorra in the show in
Siberia like all other else's on our
list
Gisela has had a happy career in musical
theatre performing in Spanish renditions
of Greece Peter Pan and many more Elsa
is a complicated and often misunderstood
character in frozen and it takes a
special actress to pull off her nuanced
vulnerability with such a believable and
powerful energy that's why it is crucial
those who play the voice of Elsa have a
strong background in Musical and
theatrical performance as they have only
their voice to use to portray the
emotion an advance plot that's why this
powerful actress was perfect to perform
Elsa in the Spanish version of frozen -
she brings her acting chops and music
experience to the foreground and
delivers an incredible performance to be
remembered by many generations to come
born September 21st 1989 Gambaccini is
one of the youngest Elsa's on our list
but age is no measure of talent or
success gamm was able to sing when she
was only three years old
winning singing contests all over
Thailand when she was still in
elementary school show business was hot
on her horizon as she quickly started
releasing albums singing soundtracks and
landing roles and musicals she also won
the television series the star in 2008
it's no surprise as she has an
incredible vocal range and she's able to
hit notes many singers only dream of
reaching she's also famous on Instagram
with over 1.4 million followers she has
a large fan base to share her career
success and keep millions of people
updated with all of her Elsa related
endeavors she also loves fashion and can
be spotted wearing some pretty sweet
outfits on the gram between singing
voice acting and being a fashion icon
GAM has made quite a wonderful career
for herself and she's only 30 so you can
expect to see a lot more of her for many
years
to come idina menzel the iconic elsa -
all frozen fans in north america she did
an amazing job at the Oscars looking
very comfortable on stage she's saying
the majority of into the unknown at the
award show and she hit every note
perfectly she also were an amazing white
silk dress with a stunning diamond
necklace it's no surprise she's one of
Broadway's most talented stars she
originated to Broadway roles in rent and
wicked and has starred in countless
other Broadway performances throughout
her career she's also made a splash in
Hollywood playing memorable roles in
films like rent enchanted and even uncut
gems in an interview with The Associated
Press Edina said it's been the greatest
gift for me to have Elsa and frozen and
to go all over the world singing these
songs
idina menzel like many of her friends
onstage at the Oscars also played alfafa
in wicked those are the 10 powerful
ladies who sang into the unknown at the
Oscars this year they all bring else's
character to life in such a unique and
special way it was so fun to see the
frozen characters in so many different
languages do you have a favorite alsa
let us know in the comments we would
love to hear from you and while you're
at it don't forget to like this video
and subscribe to the things to keep
up-to-date on all our latest content